Dr Nash and Total Transformation who is
sponsoring this next segment have been
transforming lives all across the valley
and for Dominic it's more than weight
loss take a look
working with Dr Nash I lost 70 pounds in
three and a half months and reversed my
type 2 diabetes and I feel great Dr Nash
Dominic's transformation is unbelievable
it's amazing what you've done with
Dominic tell us more about the guy yeah
so Dominic was somebody that found out
that he was pre-diabetic when he was 20
years old he worked for five years
trying to figure out through his own
methods uh what to do about it how to
lose some weight and turn it around and
ended up becoming full-blown diabetic by
the age of 25 and that's when he decided
to get serious and do something that's
when he found me he lost a hundred
pounds by the using my program and
reverse the diabetes in three months how
come how come some doctors they can they
can manage these symptoms but you're
making these drastic changes for people
how are you doing this so unfortunately
doctors hams are really tied when it
comes to diabetes because they can
really only use medication and as the
disease progresses and worsens they'll
add insulin to the equation and while
those measures will work on controlling
things like blood sugar the disease and
the disastrous symptoms will continue to
worsen and the problem is I don't think
people understand just how bad the
symptoms get we're talking blindness
amputation heart disease kidney and
liver damage and now severe fatal
outcomes with covid-19 on top of this
stubborn weight problem this obesity
that just won't go away
your cat has arrives to join our
interview today I love it when your cat
shows up that's just great I know so he
photobombed my shop out with you Jason
it's fantastic
let's talk about the five metabolic
factors that that you have right so one
of the things that I found out after my
25-year struggle with obesity is that
for me personally it was the damage that
was driving the weight problem not the
calories and exercise so those five
things are the total in The Total
Transformation so one is going to be
toxicity the other one is going to be
overfed but undernourished not getting
the proper nutrition to turn the
metabolism around the next one is going
to be the retraining of the hypothalamus
or the set point that tells your body to
stay in a certain way the A is for
acidity also known as inflammation which
drives stubborn weight to the belly and
then L is the lower the imbalanced
hormones up to seven different hormones
that if they are not in the proper
position in that body you literally
can't burn body fat and every week you
come on the show you're kind of special
for us what do you have for us today oh
you know I do so normally when people
come and talk to me when they go online
and do the evaluation it's 97. to do
that but when Las Vegas now allows me to
talk with JC about this topic that I'm
so passionate about I have 10 spots
available where we will do that online
evaluation for 9.97 you want to go to
the website to secure that spot if you
call my office they don't know about the
special they're going to try to charge
you 97 so go to that drnash.com forward
slash eval those spots go quickly and
make sure that I get a chance to talk to
you and get you the help that you need
to get well